impuissant sur le terrain puissance
diplomatique le secrétaire général de
l'onu boutros boutros ghali ne ménage
pourtant pas ses efforts et aura
l'occasion de le dire demain à midi dans
l'heure de vérité
en direct de new york patricia cost le
problème yougoslave comme une épée de
damoclès au-dessus de la tête de boutros
boutros ghali au moment où il a pris la
tête de l'onu en janvier dernier il
n'aura pas le temps de prendre la mesure
de l'énorme machine onusienne qui lui
faudra affronter cette épreuve il sera
rapidement accusé de tout et de son
contraire d'être trop prudent ou de trop
parlé d'agir au coup par coup
alors qu'il s'était fait le héraut d'une
diplomatie préventive
difficile de s'imposer huit mois
seulement après sa prise de fonction au
moment où l'onu est en faillite
et pourtant engage sa plus importante
opération au cambodge et doit faire face
à la famine en somalie
boutros boutros ghali tente de faire
face avec opiniâtreté
fort de son expérience homme de paix et
fut l'artisan des accords de camp david
entre égyptiens et israéliens
il est aussi un tiers-mondiste convaincu
ancien ministre des affaires étrangères
en egypte et les plus politique que son
prédécesseur pératé coillard et se veut
plus actif mais la conjoncture actuelle
est particulièrement difficile pour un
secrétaire général des nations unies
france 2